d'habitude quand on dit grand requin
blanc
on pense plutôt à ce genre de musique
et à ce genre de peine mais mardi au
large d'hawaï
tout était beaucoup plus calme
dans les eaux chaudes un immense requin
blanc surgit au moins six mètres de long
l'un des plus gros spécimens jamais
observé un prédateur de deux tonnes et
demie
la plongeuse grande défenseure des
squales de toutes sortes nage à ses
côtés se permet même de le caresser
elle est tellement massive
elle a l'air enceinte lily celle qui
espère que ces images exceptionnelles
change les perceptions
je veux qu'on arrête de les voir comme
des mangeurs d'homme parce que ça n'a
rien à voir avec les dents de la mer
quand l'un détruit un bateau avant
d'engloutir le pot queen l'autre n'avait
apparemment qu'une envie se servir du
bateau pour se gratter un peu mais la
spécialiste ne veut pas servir d'exemple
pour autant elle conseille tout de même
de rester loin des grands requins blancs
ici mathieu prost radio-canada ouvert